here's a ruler where is the center of
gravity well presumably in the middle
and that's certainly true if I put my
finger in the middle somewhere there
oops it balances so that's the center of
gravity but suppose that I attach some
weight at one end well where is it well
it's not so easy to guess right but
there is a very nice way of finding a
center gravity which I'll start by doing
it with that way you simply put two
fingers and to support the object and
then you bring them toward each other
and automatically you see one stop
someone starts one stops and they meet
automatically at the center gravity and
I can even do this with eyes closed
this works in general if I attach for
example a mass at one end I don't know
where the center of gravity is but my
fingers automatically find the center of
gravity and if I put a hefty mass at the
other end well the center gravity will
be really close to the end and indeed it
finds the center of gravity over here
and if I put both of them at the same
time where is it well it automatically
finds the center of gravity again I'm
not deliberately controlling the
movement my fingers I'm just bringing
them slowly toward each other and
automatically one of them starts
studying and the other stops and the
others start studying and one stops and
they meet always at the center so how
does it work it works because of a
really simple but why do the applicable
principle you know when two bodies
sliding against each other or they are
sort of stopped and they want to start
sliding there is something that's
opposing the slide and that's called
friction it turns out that the friction
is proportional to increases with the
force that's pressing the two body
against each two bodies against each
other but also is proportional to some
coefficient the factor matter it's very
very widely established observational
fact when you are studying the friction
is slightly smaller than when years
top ten wanted to start sliding we
talked about the difference between the
dynamic friction that's the friction
that's acting when the ball is already
sliding versus static friction when
these two bodies are stopped at against
each other and then they want to start
slightly static friction is a little
larger than the dynamic friction okay
suppose that I start bringing those two
fingers toward each other whether they
some random error in the beginning so
first this finger started moving for
some reason okay when this finger is
closer to the center of gravity than
this finger this finger is taking more
weight over the ruler than this finger
so there is more friction there and so
because there's more friction on this
finger than on this finger
naturally the finger that slides is this
one but you see once this finger starts
starting it's starting with dynamic
friction whereas this is stopped at
static friction so in principle you see
when these are at equal distances from
it from the center of centre of gravity
they take equal weights so they should
have equal frictions but that's not true
because this is already sliding so it's
taking the sliding friction dynamic
friction
whereas this is taking static friction
so this one can keep sliding although
it's taking more and more weight because
it's friction is a little less than this
one so it overshoots towards the center
and when it's really close then the
other one starts moving and so on that's
why they alternate stick-slip mechanism
this is called slip sticks lip stick and
then they come toward each other so if
you take a weighted version well for a
long time this left finger slides
because left as seen from your sides
because it's of course far from the
center of gravity so it has a decimate
on it so it has less friction but it
overshoots and then the other one starts
starting over shoots over shoots over
shoots and then they finally meet in the
center so this mechanism is using the
slightly difference between the dynamic
and Static frictions and the fact that
well when you come at equal distances
from the center of gravity the one
that's already sliding come over shoot
and then once that stops it stays there
for a while and then
only when the other starting finger has
stopped
kunti this one starts sliding again and
then overshoot and come towards them and
so on they come towards them is there an
accepted number of times there will be a
slip and a stick right over the course
of 30 centimeters that is arbitrary that
is very very that's an excellent
question I think it's a case-by-case and
you can do a very very precise
calculation using a simple model of
stick slip and so forth but the fact of
the matter is that it is a very unstable
process I mean depending on tiny tiny
regularities of the surface and so on
and the number seems to vary quite a lot
so and I think we have to resort to just
experiments and the theoretical
calculation does give some picture but I
don't think it gives really as accurate
in a prediction as the numbers suggest
paper clips is linked with our band but
not between themselves let's finish with
something that is working progress so
far we have been linking paper clips
together and sometimes we refer to this
as addition